the gyro can experience what could be
done to radically curb this you know
like if you were the king of the world
said Edie what are we going to do first
off legalizing sums up some of the
substances would probably help that
would help a lot that's a pretty good
question but even some substances that
are legal like fentanyl is essentially
legal because you can get a prescription
for it
but you're never gonna have like
fentanyl just over-the-counter it's just
too deadly you know another thing that
you know I think about and that's a very
good question I wish I could answer I
think everybody wishes they can answer
it and everyone just sort of like shrugs
and so the the cartels aren't just a
drug filled business mmm they also have
money that is in property and legitimize
businesses they work in human
trafficking like they actually it used
to be you can cross that border and go
to the desert and cross it yourself but
now you have to pay a toll protection
rackets across the both sides of the of
the border sex trafficking piracy like
you name it they have they have hands in
it right so so they just essentially
took that drug money and just did a
crime business he's diversified they've
been diversified for a long time like
yeah there was a recently two three
three cartel members from Sinaloa in
Malaysia released out of all places so
you just think about that - Sinaloa
cartel guys somewhere in Malaysia got
caught somewhere and now they've been
released and the Attah like a hero's
welcome in Mexico to get a hero's
welcome oh yeah really
we'll see the law that you know they're
getting seen a low as a pretty that's uh
I have this nickname for Mexico I call
it the upside down you know because
everything's being basically upside down
now right and yeah these guys got funny
thing is that the Mexican government was
involved in their release and then they
you know send them back and you know
hero's welcome what were they doing all
the way over there and that
the world you know diversifying
diversifying so no one has a real plan
here goes Malaysia pardons three
Mexicans on death row oh they were on
death row damn you want to talk about a
kick-ass Garrido
unlike a folk song song about you those
guys are probably gonna get an amazing
folk song you know so there's a lot of
romanticism yeah I mean it's it's
romanticism it's religion there's
definitely some some occultism involved
in a lot of the higher-ups in these
cartels I remember when I found out
about the narco music these what are
those songs called corridos yeah the
folk songs there's a lot of them you
know there's uh and they all of them
have a secret language in them sometimes
or they're all a history of something to
happened and you pay somebody that -
just to make one for you or somebody
makes it for you and then if you do what
a good career song for somebody and the
rivals will send somebody to kill you
you know so like even even the musicians
are on other side of the cartel kind of
groupings as well it's pretty weird I
don't but it's Wow so if you're if
you're for the wrong car tell you if you
make a song you kind of have to like go
into hiding or or not play in any places
where the rival cartels know territories
are oh Jesus Christ
will they come to your territory to come
get you if you ya know yeah there's
there's finna be up in a few high-level
singers Mexican folk singers that got
their you know killed for messin with
girlfriends with cartel members or for
singing the wrong song in the wrong
place so that's in the culture and and
the religious occultism the cartels have
as well you know it's a pretty
interesting thing
things like Santa Marta they're the the
death cult that is kind of in different
parts of New Mexico it's like think of a
very dark
Freemasonry type thing right some
certain levels you have people that are
part of the part of that cult
the cops to the military to the cartels
it's kind of to prostitutes to drug
dealers
it's interesting how how that kind of
also has an influence on on the way some
people go into very risky businesses
like being cops or cartel guys and how
they wear or they empower themselves by
some of these cult iconographies you
know like or or there's the Trinity is a
Susan malvada which is uh it was a folk
hero from turn over the centuries you
know law basically abandoned that got
caught and killed and he turned into a
Satan now there's a giant Church to him
in Sinaloa with a bunch of money stuck
to the walls and and pictures of guys in
the US with like a f-150 truck or a
Hummer like thank you mile burger I'm
living the dream now because of you Wow
two roadside altars with with a statue
of the Virgin Mary and you look behind
her and there's a Reaper behind it
because it's a hidden Santa Marta shrine
and they do that so the military doesn't
destroy him because they have standing
orders to destroy these things which
shouldn't be but you know kind of
religious persecution but they actually
do that it's so it's so different than
the United States in a lot of ways it is
I mean I don't think we understand like
all this stuff I think the average
person has no idea about the songs no
idea about the culture of it all they
have no idea the depth and how deeply
it's connected Society down there I mean
the death the death cult worship is I
think you could probably trace it back
to the Aztec days all right so there's
definitely when you see all these highly
graph highly violent bloody cartel
executions and and things like that I
don't know I mean yeah I think there's
some sort of genetic memory from that of
those times it's not abnormal physically
for some of these people do that type of
thing you know ripping somebody's heart
next to a tree is there's videos of that
stuff out there remember getting
contacted by people
I knew on this side of the border in the
US that were very curious why all these
people from the Middle East were looking
at all these cartel execution videos and
then a few years later you had Isis
doing some high production execution
videos then we're inspired by the
cartels you know Wow so is that
interesting that we don't think about
that we think about oh my god look at
Isis they're cutting people's heads off
whatever they learned from Mexico which
is connected to us by lambs right
they're [ __ ] walk they're like you
have to fly to Afghanistan you could
walk there it's not in Libya it's near
La Joya yeah you go to La Jolla you see
these [ __ ] multimillion-dollar
estates with his gorgeous view and
everyone's driving Ferraris and Porsches
20 minutes drive you're in Tijuana yeah
the most violent city on the planet
right now that's so crazy
yeah and when I go to San Diego that's
the one of the first things I think is
how what adjusts to position how crazy
it is that this is the border to Mexico
and it's all military San Diego is
filled with [ __ ] seals and Rangers
and Marines and bases it's just all
military down there sits so military
influence and it's right next to the
most violent dangerous city on planet
earth more than Karachi more than
Pakistan we were as we were insured by
MetLife and the Met Life agent said said
something along those lines like you're
better off going to Afghanistan or Iraq
than you know working here basically
numbers-wise
and I was like thank you for that you
know that felt that felt like a good pat
on the back but it seems like they're
getting cartel on cartel crime yeah
fused with regular person crime so but
that's how it always starts you know
usually starts off and again this goes
back to everything cyclical down there
that that snake eating its tail so you
get cartel on cartel crime and then they
finish each other off and then they
realize well now now what do we do
so they started producting people
extortion just for money just extortion
comes out and to play you know
protection rackets
cross us guy and now they're very bold
that now they're at the party somewhere
and somebody looks at them funny so they
come back and they shoot up the whole
party I like your daughter she's pretty
hot I'm gonna steal her and if you do
something I'll kill you and you're never
gonna see your daughter again that's how
it starts you know that's that's how it
start kind of growing just bold brazen
cruel that's how you get it sociopathic
that's how you get say get to that point
and then again I experienced it back in
the 2006 era and I saw it get into all
the way to when the whole of the
municipal police were they basically the
army surrounded the municipal police
office of the police in Tijuana and they
took all the guns and a few of them were
taking on a plane ride to Mexico City
and there for a few weeks there was no
armed police in Tijuana and the
municipal armed police imagine somebody
imagine somebody disarming the whole LP
all of the LAPD and just having the army
in there instead you know wow so you
would see you would see these events and
then things calming down you know the
only success story as far as us as far
as the city coming back from the brink
was Tijuana for what wouldn't all that
like the raging drug war went down
lieutenant colonel Issa all of the guy
that I used to work with he took numbers
down like everybody down in Mexico he
had got hired then on to go to Huaraz to
try and replicate his success the only
successes were there because he
basically treated the problem as a
counter insurgent problem mmm and he had
he got nine attempts on his life the
last one took the use of his legs and
he's currently currently running for
mayor of Tijuana believer huh and he's
he's in a wheelchair but he still I
wouldn't wanna mess with that guy Wow
yeah we were
Fatma myself and some members of my
family are actually helping out with his
campaign but he's you know he got de is
one of his campaign offices got shut up
shut up recently
so is there any plans or the is there
any push to try to treat the entire
problem as a counterinsurgency problem
to replicate the success that they had
in Tijuana
no it's it's uh that was a solution
brought in by the right side of the
political spectrum in the in Mexico so
it's it's a no-go right now because
everything's still left this guy just
got in office he's uh he's up he's has a
few months in so yeah he just got into
office so so you got five and a half
more years of this dude we're in for a
ride that's all I can say yeah
kindness doesn't seem to work when it
you're dealing with cartels it seems
like no you give him a hand a little
take your feet that's that was that said
Mexican say ah man it for you to have
been in that business and to sort of be
connected to about side of it now it did
it seemed like does it seem I mean it
must be incredibly frustrating but it
also must feel futile like you've wasted
time almost because not there's no no
progress is ever going to be made I have
a you know have a weird experience that
I had burned about two acres of pot
somewhere in Baja right towards the end
of my career and then things happen
politically a bunch of sheiks a bit
Jacobs over the office I got called in
and the director at that of the
institution that I was in at that time
was a shady character and I decided to
say you know what my mom had just passed
away and that kind of affected me a
little bit a lot of a lot of it you know
and starting a family and stuff like
that and you know it said you know what
this is this is not worth it so I left
quit my job handed everything in people
were suspicious about why I did it you
know
let me probably found a million dollars
somewhere in your writing or [ __ ] like
that right so I had to leave in a hurry
you know we got a few threats
gladly I gladly I had luckily I had some
great people on this side of the
border friendships that I developed for
a long while and they helped me out you
know
[Applause]